all right please bear with us for a
moment as you can see we have Krishna
Kumar uh Christian Kumar here who is our
CEO of Simply learn and
um
who is one of our program graduates and
we'll start the conversation with them
in just a moment first I have to
begin our live stream for our LinkedIn
please bear with us for a moment as you
can see
this just takes
a few seconds
all right and Welcome to our LinkedIn
live audience our YouTube live audience
and also to the folks here on our WebEx
event
and
our event today is
a success story and it's a conversation
between uh thucker and Krishna Kumar
um about ritanje's experience with
the
full stack Java developer program and
how it's changed his career so
um
with that a little bit about simply
learn
take it away
Krishna
uh you're on the mute I'm sorry
it automatically mutes uh thanks for the
setting up this call so and welcome to
this um webinar and thanks for giving
your time to speak with me and also the
attendees were part of this call so I
wanted to start this conversation uh
from a start from your introductions
it'll be great if you can introduce
yourself in terms of where do you belong
to what's your educational qualification
and what are you currently doing
yeah so thank you for simply for giving
me the uh for this learning and so uh I
did my MSC in 2021 from Reva University
Bangalore in the biotechnology basically
I am not from uh the IIT background and
uh after the completion of the MSC I
joined the master programs in full start
Java developer uh for research basically
I'm from madhya Pradesh yes sir
gaming private Limited is it a poker
based company
oh okay got it and what is your job
there
uh I'm a gadget engineer training and
I'm working as a Java developer how big
is your team
uh yeah in my company like 16 15 to 16
in uh
uh enclosing the Java team got it so you
worked with a team lead and and you're
part of a bigger team yes yes
foreign
so what made you make that decision
right because people generally when they
study a certainly fail they want to work
in that particular field so what was the
trigger point for you to decide that you
want to become a Java developer yeah
actually uh my brother he is also the
web developer so he suggested me about
this course so he had almost four years
of experience in it field so in the
beginning we were confused regarding
course during the college project uh
while while checking the content so
regarding courses so while checking the
content of the simply learn so my
brother was full uh impressed and told
it was a complete package of industrial
skill set so during college projects
some uh some interest was developed in
Java so if I will talk about the
opportunity it will be uh tremendous and
hard skills and which will help a you
which will help the when the growth
exponentially I saw people having 80
years of experience and earning a 640 to
60 lakh per annum yeah so
yeah so almost done so once we joined
this program so how did did you consider
any other program before joining the
simply run program
hello
yeah my brother suggested due to the
because of the content was so good and
it is the industrial based content
got it so tell me about the program
itself so how long it took for you to
complete the program
how many hours we are spending in
learning the Java while you are part of
the program
yeah so this course is almost nine month
and daily I am spending photo learning
Java uh for four to five five hours
daily I'm spending on this course
yeah okay so when you had any doubts so
so what was the process one is that you
must be attending our classes but let's
say after the class is over and if you
want to take any help
yes if you want to take in help what was
the process like were you in touch with
some teaching assistant how was
how was it the whole overall experience
of getting instant help in case you
wanted some help yeah actually
um we have a Saturday and Sunday classes
if we ever doubt in the class so then we
can ask in the in between of the class
and if we have a doubt after the class
so then we can raise the ticket in the
some from the simple learn dashboard and
within that 12 hour we can uh we can get
the response and they will arrange
whatever the doubt is there they will
arrange any faculty or something so how
many how many times to use that like
doubt clarification did you use it more
frequently or you use it only once in a
one once in a while what
no I used frequently
um whenever I got that out I used this
I raised the ticket and I got the
solution within a 12 hours
or as soon as possible
got it okay so I think there is somebody
asking also that after completion I have
some doubt what do I do it so I think
just from messenger is explaining that
he used to login into the LMS and and
raise a ticket and then somebody would
respond
to their particular ticket and clarify
the doubt
so
yes sir yeah
and there's also questions that I want
some placement opportunities so I think
all those of you who are part of
simplified program uh placement
opportunities will come right and that's
why we take time right we take at least
six months time to ensure that everybody
gets opportunities so keep be in touch
with your point of contact and as and
when there is an opportunity we'll it
will be sent to your will and we have a
large team of people who are
continuously working on creating new
opportunities so it's not going to
happen in one single day but happy since
continue to practice and the opportunity
will definitely come your way
the question is when that's why you see
opportunities don't come in a single day
right
you have you completed your graduation
you have completed your engineering
right so to have time you
the suggested time is that within six
months you definitely get opportunities
and keep for the steps that will that's
been suggested by the Learning success
manager that continuously applies for a
job right
so because there's a question for you
that how many after completion of your
program when when did you get your
placement
after completion of my program a very in
a two month in two months I get good
place and initially I actually I got the
uh um like job uh um I gave the
interview from the simpleton like 20 to
25 companies initially I am not selected
in the I have almost all the most of the
companies I cleared the second and third
round
um then after that uh in the uh in the
second month uh within a I think uh in
the second one I got the six offers
which provider companies which is
provided by the simply loans
when you have appeared for multiple
interviews what was your learning like
did you learn something from first
from first went back and and did more
preparation before he went for the
second interview
yeah definitely whenever I gave the
interview I learned the new things like
what are the questions they will ask and
um what are the quoting questions and
how they take the assessment and uh so
yeah for yeah whenever I gave the
interview I learned the new things so
within a two months I got pleased and
after after in the second month I go I
was six offers so the in the current
company which I am working I go here is
I got the good package so I select this
this one but
did you had some other friends also in
their class like who had a similar
experience or your how many students
were you in touch
currently I'm not in touch with anyone
yeah but uh one of my uh yeah with one
I'm in touch yeah he got selected in the
he's in Hyderabad he also did this goal
same in my badge he also got selected
and one of employee who is my in my
company he is a senior he also uh did
this simply on course
our developer course
so when you uh
appeared in multiple companies
like all the the interview format of all
the companies were similar or you found
a few things similar and few things not
being similar when you appeared for so
many different companies but what has
been your learning there yeah some of
the company like in the first round some
of the company will ask about the
assessment like in the assessment
reasoning questions and some of the
company will give the projects like for
uh like for the Java uh Java coding or a
springboard project some of the company
give the springboard project and after
that assessment uh then the two or three
technical rounds is there two technical
rounds is there and one coding around is
there
got it so for coding around see there
are some coding practice that's included
as part of the project was that
sufficient or you also did some more
coding practice on your own on
if so can you tell me where all you
spend time learning more doing more
practice on coding
yeah actually after the completion of
course simply also provided the like
sessions for practicing the coding
uh so I uh assemblyn provided that means
and the industrial expert that who took
the session and yeah enough from after
the and I am also practicing about the
coding after
hello
I was looking at some of those questions
to see if I can have something relevant
Richard I was had a question of my own
which was uh how did your brother find
out about simply learn
yeah actually he is um he's a friend he
did this course
so he his friend also got the job from
the simpleton so he suggested me that
the course
okay so what what was your brother had
done
no my brother is doing a my brother's
friend they did this course that fully
struck Java developer course so he had
also done the full uh yes yes yes so my
brothers a few 102 friend did this
course and they also got placed and he
also see the content of that course so
he impressed with that course and he
already have a he have a long experience
of four plus four plus years in the web
development
okay
so here done this course long bed
yes yes
got it
so so your brother was not a fresher
when he took this course
no actually I was saying like my
brother's friend
they did this course equipment
yeah
so tell me among of all the course
topics that was taught are there topics
that you find found it easier are the
topics that you found it difficult and
how did it went about like understanding
some of the difficult topics that you
got as part of the program
your difficult topic yeah like when I'm
in MSC in the MSC I started learning
about the uh that programming things
from myself yeah but I don't have so
much knowledge about that programming
after the when I joined this course so I
learned the oops Concepts so oops
Concepts and the Java and spring boot
yeah so these are the my favorite topics
like Java oops Concepts and the spring
Boot and uh yes and uh I also learned
the in this course angular JavaScript
and HTML CSS so these are the
interesting topic which uh
and the learning experience was a very
good
am very good from the simple line and I
learned both the front-end the back-end
technology and I also learned the Java
DL data structures and the springboard J
unit mochito and the devops
and if you are topping if we are talking
about the content of this course this
was good and completion of a there is a
complete after the completion of each uh
topic there is an assignment so we have
you have to submit that assignment also
so you will get the uh the and the
learning support was also good
yes so I think there is there are some
people who are who are putting some
question marks and asking some questions
uh related to a job and some of them are
also in this disbelief that okay uh
maybe you are not a real Learners and
somebody else is coming and speaking on
your behalf to all those guys is I want
to make uh sure that I want to just make
a statement to all of you that any
program that you take the first step is
that start with the conviction that you
can do it there are all the reasons to
not believe that I can do a program and
I can get a job
this particular person he is available
on LinkedIn and he works in a real
company that company also is available
on LinkedIn if you start with a
disbelief that okay nothing is going to
happen nobody can help you
nobody can can help you and nobody can
help you ever
and not only him there are other
Learners also who are available on
LinkedIn who have done the program and
if you search for simply learn student
you will get at least 100 000 students
one lakh or more students on LinkedIn
who have completed this program
okay so I think you can have all kinds
of disbelief and then decide not to do
but I don't think anybody can help you
in that regard the only way to become
successful is that have faith do the
program properly follow the steps that
we are suggesting and and definitely
you'll get the definitely you'll meet
the intended objective for which you
have signed up for the program
and uh one more thing from my side also
um like whatever the classes like
classes you are attended after the
completion of the class you can get the
recorded video from the simple website
LMS so you have to watch at least once
or twice each video then you will get
the proper understanding about the topic
and you have also submit the assignment
don't copy paste from the Googles only
you have to make create from your one
then you will get the proper
understanding about the topic
yes
so once you started working in this
company what additional things that you
learned on the job
yeah in the job like first when I joined
this job first I got the architecture
level
task like first I told you have to
create the that sequence diagram and the
flow diagram and yeah first time I did
these things about the whatever the apis
are already created so they gave the
architecture level task after that
um they gave me the task about the
create the API and also they gave me the
devops work also like
build on the build the application on
devops yeah so this can and also created
a like IO I joined this company in the
last last three months last and I
already created 10 to 15 apis in that
company
so when you join this company where
there are were there other uh people
like you who join as a graduate training
yeah
yeah from along with me
um one more guy is joined as a casual
attendant and what was his background
uh he is a computer science background
so he had also done some course so he
directly joined this he directly joined
this
uh he got placed from his college
okay it was a through the college
placement yes yes
not really
good
anything else that you want to share
with Ninja other than I already asked
um
yes like
it's like there are there are uh like
two kinds of people one who are
completely fresher who want to take some
learning program to get their first job
and then there are people who are who
have some experience and they want to
take up the program I'm sure in your
batch also there will be people of both
the types right there are people who are
yes completely fresher and there are
people who are who have some experience
so
did you see any difference in their
approach in terms of learning and
they're they're getting opportunities
after completing the program
yes so first thing I I will say like um
yeah non-it background will also are
doing this course so first of all first
of all if you join the uh this the
content of this course is very good and
uh so you uh and each topic there is an
assignment so you have to submit that
assignment and then which uh The
Learning Experience uh the learning
support uh was also good and if whatever
the query or doubts which uh I uh which
you get you can raise the ticket for
this and the lives and you can watch at
least twice the live sessions and please
take assignment seriously and you need
to make your hand dot T and it will not
work by just watching the video you have
to do more practice from yourself and
yeah yeah so so you're suggesting that
you should do do the project on your own
and don't try to like take help from
others in the class and try to complete
the project right yes yes
I think at our hour and also we try to
identify people who have not done
project on your own and definitely flag
them out but I agree that if you really
want to learn it's for your own interest
like you can't have the approach of just
copying pasting and trying to get
project from somewhere else I think the
more practice that you do the more
project that you try to do on your own
side and in the process if you have
doubt and you ask our teaching assistant
as well as instructor in clarifying them
I think that will definitely help in
learning and also helping you get the
job yes
okay
so I think it's a great talking to you
Mr I I think one of the reasons I also
wanted to speak to you that I directly
also want to understand how is your
learning experience so thank you for
your time and I think next time maybe
you'll invite a couple of Learners
together who did this program and got
job into various companies so that you
guys can also maybe talk to each other
also and exchange notes
okay sure okay okay thank you thank you
for your time bye-bye thank you sir bye
bye
foreign
thank you everybody for being here with
us
and uh
if that concludes uh the conversation I
think that's the end of the webinar but
I will want to share with you
um one
last thing before we go
Krishna did you want to talk about the
um
program that's coming up
no I think that's that's fine
okay okay all right okay but we do here
we do have thank you very much thank you
bye-bye